another question we've got here says how
many hours would you generally spend on
revision per week leading up to exams
and I'm sure that we'll all give quite
different answers to this mmm
I don't know it depends how hard you
work how much effort you put in when you
are working I can't really give you a
yes there's no distinction in that
question between how many hours I did
spend on revision per week and how many
hours I should have done there's some
people who always work far too much or
too little and should you know you thing
I think yeah I think I wouldn't advise
being specific on the number of hours
it's mainly if you're feeling productive
and that could be short intense bursts
or longer and then one other thing I do
say is find quite useful ism if you have
like I know this is quite good for
history and I'm not sure about science
but there's probably there's lots of
popular science podcast population
podcast stuff like that um they're free
and if you just get one that you solve
quite like my profile one called Rex
factor which is quite useful and it's
quite fun so I just put that on in the
background like well I'm sort of making
tea or something and it's just so funny
and relaxing also just sort of helps
cement some of the basics in your head
yeah there is definitely coming up to
digging sounds at the end of uni but I
think it happens in any sort of exams
there's kind of an assumption an
unspoken assumption that revision must
inherently be horrible or be a difficult
thing or be tiring and that sort of
stuff but it really doesn't have to be
just you just have to kind of have have
the confidence that only doing a certain
amount a day and sleeping like you may
not see any eating and exercising lots
of stuff you don't need to cram in the
library all the time because they're not
often us when people are their least
productive that for someone asked how
valuable do you think the tutorials are
with relevant to your advancement in
your course obviously the first thing to
say is that tutorials aren't like
coursework or things like that or like
periodic assessments that you
at suburban universities and they don't
count towards your final result so it's
important to make that point but the
tutorials for any subject really are
meant to be a discussion about the
subject matter that clarifies what
you've been doing in your own time I
think that'd be fair to say across both
the humanities and the sciences so it's
an opportunity for the tutor on a weekly
or more often basis to check that you've
understood what you learn what your what
you'd be reading and that you have a foe
understanding of the topic well then
just be able to put it down on paper if
that makes sense
and so I find incredibly applewhite
helpful I really really enjoyed my
tutorial because they're inherently
interesting discussions the tutors are
brilliant yeah yeah get some real
characters often for the history
tutorials often you bring your the essay
you've written in the week with you to
the tutorial some cheaters ask you to
read them out and you coming on and
that's all stuff so it's not tuned to
basically to provide feedback on the
actual thing you've written in the week
but also feedback just generally on how
you understand topic and also I find a
quiz go for like you can ask the G like
if there's something that you had sort
of a bit versal idea that you're not
sure if it's actually something that's
right or not you can like ask them about
it and they can sort of develop it and
tell you if it's good or bad it's a good
way it's a good way of sort of getting
to grips with yes a nice way of
particularly in during the application
process of thinking about whether you
like the way which Oxford teaches its
undergraduates is to try and have as
many conversations with different people
about the subjects as possible on your
subject teachers at school obviously
being a fairly good place to start and
see whether you in because know it's not
for everyone
that's seeing whether you enjoy having
those conversations and
you find them useful yeah and beyond the
course as well the tutorial system is
what's that's Oxford and Cambridge apart
from all the other Nini employers know
that you will apply tutorials and you
will have been interrogated thoroughly
on stuff that the stuff you know and
that's something that stands out when
you're going for interviews you'll have
the tech know those techniques you'll be
able to talk about things to someone
else one-on-one without feeling nervous
you won't be afraid of asking their
stupid questions so it's really useful
yeah necessary which could cut across
different subjects like I did a tutorial
an 18th century India which whatever
sort of jobs I applied for his fame am
likely to come into it come into the job
application but the idea of having taken
a subject I knew you next to nothing
about a week before reading over in a
week and I be able to talk about it with
an expert they've been hour and a half
that is something quite special which
importance of getting recognized but
whatever degree you can do
you